[Music]
after 100 days in the digital area we
have paved the road already we want to
take there what we want to take for
citizens but also a business and for
governments the European Green Deal is
known to everybody we're working
steadily on this transition like things
as the just transition mechanism or the
climate law that has just been put
forward but many other steps to follow
over the next weeks and months finding a
solution to this situation will require
we leaving the pressure that is put on
the border we will put forward our new
European migration pact right after
Easter now there is a new perspective
also thanks to our balanced proposal the
new methodology which makes the
enlargement process more speedy more
reliable and more credible our efforts
to help Albania reconstruct after the
devastating earthquake have gone a long
way to restore faith and to restore
trust in the European Union we have as
you know within the Commission a corona
response team that is working with the
Member States under known issues this
all couldn't have been done without a
fantastic team of commissioners and vice
presidents that are very dedicated